Nhi Anh, mấy hai đường lấy nước tồ đầu vào trước cắt nhờ máy ở mấy hai hội bị ôi dẫn,
báo đậu ở điểm khi hợp, bị nhiễm ở sên vượt gướng 2 milần.
Sựa tên quyền vào môi trường tình như anh, vừa có công văn tạnh báo về chất lượng nước tồ đầu vào cấp cho chạp,
nhà mấy nước trên địa bàn theo đó, công văn này được gửi tới các khệnh hương miên,
in thành, khuy hợp, thành trường, quyền lục, tân kỳ, ghi lục, năng đàn, sĩnh châu,
thì giả cửa lỏ, phí giả thái hòa, phí giả hòa mai, đây là những địa phương phát hiện ôi những sâu khi còn chất mống nước tồ đầu vào.
Cụ thể, mống nước lấy tại một nước tồ đầu vào của hệ thống cấp nước in thành,
có hai thông số vượt quyền chuẩn, công xeo dê vượt môi phép bá mấy bà lên, tế et vượt môi phy sáo lên.
Mống nước lấy tại một nước tồ đầu vào của nhà mới nước phy chân quy hợp,
có bá thông số vượt quyền chuẩn, a sên vượt 2 môi phy bà lên,
khá đi bí vượt môi phy chín mới tâm lên, bèo xe năm vượt môi phép môi trăm bệ bí lâm lên.
Môi nước tồ đầu vào của hệ thống cấp nước quy châu, có bá thông số vượt quyền chuẩn,
a đẹ vượt môi phép môi trăm lý tâm lên, tế et vượt môi phy sáo mới từ lên,
xeo dê vượt môi phy môi phy môi phy môi sáo lên.
Môi nước tồ đầu vào của hệ quy phong, có một tồ số vượt quyền chuẩn,
là xeo dê vượt môi phy năm mấy hài lên.
Môi nước tồ đầu vào tại thì giả thái hòa,
có hài thông số là tế et vượt bí nâm môi sáo lên,
tòa xeo dê vượt môi phy năm mấy lâm lên.
Môi nước tồ đầu vào tại hệ thống chuẩn,
có bá thông số là et et vượt môi phy không sáo lên,
bèo xe năm vượt môi phy mấy lâm lên,
tế et et vượt môi phy môi sáo lên.